gute noten aus der stadtschützen kaserne
auch wir tiroler soldaten von stadtlohn
sechs wollen uns an der aktion eine
million liegestütz challenge von sascha
huber beteiligen hierzu haben wir das
gesamte derzeit verfügbare kaderpersonal
rekruten oscar anwärter aktiviert und
wir werden mit insgesamt acht einheiten
in vier garnisonen teilnehmen
dh mit dem 3d zentrum in hochfilzen der
jäger company st der abc und lehrer
komponieren absam so wie hier mit der
stabskompanie der welt der kompanie nach
schutz und transport company und
führungsunterstützung company und jetzt
bock muss
das talent selbst haben möchte wandert
wo wölfe über lissabon
[Musik]
basis war sich 34 65 66 67 68 sehr gut
10.000 253 liegestütz das ist unser
beitrag für die 1 million klee
geschäftsprozesse über nachdem
weihnachten unmittelbar vor der tür
steht und die aktion seinem ende zu geht
werden wir keine weitere nominierungen
vornehmen
wir wünschen allen eine gesegnete
weihnacht einen guten rutsch